Fantastical scripts can take us to some
strange places and the things the
characters endure in these stories can
have their actors dealing with some
unbelievable conditions sometimes even
questioning if they want to be actors
anymore at all number one you've heard
of waterboarding but what about wine
boarding Game of Thrones actor Hannah
waddingham got to learn all about wine
boarding for this scene there was
strapped to a wooden table with proper
big straps for 10 hours and definitely
other than childbirth which is the worst
day of my life Hannah's scene partner
Lena Headey said she didn't enjoy
filming the scene either though she was
lucky enough to avoid any physical pain
having to pour wine onto her co-star's
face for so long and knowing how it was
distressing her fellow actor was tough
Lena felt so guilty about what she was
doing that she deliberately missed
waddingham's face on several occasions
number two not your average Joe you act
Penn Badgley said playing Joe takes a
toll on his psyche but also called it a
deep psychological exploration he said
all the reasons that I dislike him are
all the reasons that I find it an
interesting role an interesting project
there are a number of scenes that would
be uncomfortable to film but for pen one
in particular stands out the season one
finale finds Joe outside Beck's
apartment for the scene Penn said he did
not want to do the scene the actor
recalled that's what Joe was doing
that's what I had to enact I found
myself surprisingly disgusted number
three dark Betty no thanks Riverdale
actor Lily Reinhardt asked the
production to stop including dark Betty
scenes because she found them so
uncomfortable to film saying I think it
kind of became a mockery of itself with
regard to her character's Alter Ego Lily
said it was supposed to be this dark
side of her that she wasn't able to
express otherwise and it just became
this weird sexual thing that people
didn't really understand number four
riding a dragon is no easy task just ask
Game of Thrones actor kit Harrington
Harrington had heard from his castmate
Emilia Clark that filming the dragon
scenes was difficult but didn't know
just how bad it could be until he got to
try it himself kit said it was horrific
it's not acting at all it's not acting
it will never be acting and it is not
what I'd signed up for it is very
uncomfortable as a man somehow Kitt
managed to get some sensitive areas
caught in the mechanical bull he was
riding saying in my head I thought this
is how it ends on this Buck fortunately
the actor didn't suffer any long-term
damage number five flying on a broom
isn't as fun as it seems Harry Potter
actor Daniel Radcliffe shared that he
was not fond of any of the Quidditch
scenes he filmed in the Harry Potter
series Daniel said quidditch is right up
there with the least fun things I've
ever done on Harry Potter it's not a
pleasant experience it does hurt quite a
lot and it's not something I would rush
back to number 6. Chris Pratt doesn't
like bullies even if they are characters
while filming scenes for Parks and
Recreation Chris realized he hated
filming certain scenes and they weren't
even his own Pratt expressed his dislike
of the pranks and mean-spirited
treatment of Gary slash Jerry slash
Larry Terry Garrett Pratt shared he
wasn't happy with the character's
treatment on screen saying it's getting
a bit over the top I like Jim O'Hare too
much for us to be mean to him all the
time number 7. Celeste Wright went
through a lot Nicole Kidman's character
in big little lies is a wife abused by
her violent husband and the performance
left Kidman emotionally exhausted Nicole
shared I felt very exposed and
vulnerable and deeply humiliated at
times I remember lying on the floor in
the bathroom and I just wouldn't get up
in between takes number eight nude and
Afraid Emilia Clarke knows all about it
the Game of Thrones actor describes her
nude scenes as terrifying to shoot
Emilia said I'd been on a film set twice
before then and I'm now on a film set
completely naked with all of these
people and I don't know what I meant to
do and I don't know what's expected of
me however Amelia also said that co-star
Jason Momoa helped make her feel safe in
their love scenes showing her how to get
through the awkward experience and
demanding proper treatment for the
actress number nine accidentally locked
up for real filming intense scenes for
Game of Thrones can be an emotionally
demanding task and sometimes a
physically draining one as well just ask
actor Indira Varma whose character was
chained up using manacles and were
causing problems while shooting
sometimes they were too loose and
slipped off the actor's wrists but they
could also be painfully tied at other
times worst of all Indira Varma actually
got stuck inside her manacles at the end
of the day unable to free herself a
member of the props Department had to
use a saw to set the actress free number
10 eat your heart out while filming Game
of Thrones Emilia Clarke's character had
to eat the raw heart of a stallion
rather than eating a real heart Emilia
Clark had to consume a fake one
consisting of solidified jam it might
sound simple and maybe even tasty but it
wasn't according to Clark it tasted more
like a mixture of bleach and Pasta in
the scene we see her character eat one
heart but because of the various takes
Clark had to bite into 28 fake Parts
unsurprisingly Emilia struggled finding
herself involuntarily sputtering and
even vomiting a few times at least she
didn't need to worry about her
performance too much there was no need
to act when the fake hearts were so
gross number 11. a vegetarian nightmare
while shooting the Revenant Leonardo
DiCaprio's character makes a meal of a
raw bison liver but it was actually a
real Raw Liver any meat eater might have
struggled with this but the fact that
Leo is usually a vegetarian made this an
even more difficult moment to film
number 12. going nowhere fast for the
filming of the force awakens the cast
and crew spent the first part of the
films production in the Blazing desert
heat of Abu Dhabi actors Daisy Ridley
and John boyega trained on treadmills
for all the running they'd have to do
but that didn't prepare them for the
added challenge of running on Sand
Ridley said running on the combination
of hard and soft sand was killer on the
legs and she was thankful for the shots
that included explosions because that
usually meant fewer takes number 13.
what's it like to act while blind just
ask Game of Thrones actor Ian Beatty
Ian's character had to endure multiple
stab wounds to his torso and his eyes
Ian wasn't actually hurt during the
filming but the actor had to wear
Prosthetics over his eyes which meant he
was completely blinded for several hours
during the last day of filming number 14
this scene made Jessica Alba want to
stop acting while filming the scene for
Fantastic Four Rise of the Silver Surfer
Jessica Alba was challenged with
portraying the death of her character
soon the challenge was that Jessica was
acting the scene too well director Tim's
story alleged said as she was filming it
looks too real it looks too painful can
you be prettier when you cry cry pretty
Jessica don't do that with your face
just make it flat we can CGI the tears
in this made her feel like her emotions
and instincts just weren't good enough
number 15 looking cool and feeling cold
that's how Denzel felt when filming
equalizer Washington got pretty tired of
filming the scene where his character
Robert sets off the sprinklers in a
warehouse the movie's ending took days
to film Denzel said he understood that
the fire sprinklers pouring water all
over the scene looked cool but wasn't
into it especially after filming
multiple 13-hour days
with scripts and stories getting bigger
and more bizarre we know this is only a
short list of scenes that actors found
themselves struggling to film so what do
you think what did we miss let us know
in the comments below